in the recent couple of weeks there's
been a definite military buildup around
Tripoli with forces affiliated with Fete
bashada Gathering and mobilizing on the
outskirts of Tripoli and returned the PM
to veba has gathered forces and they
were on high alert so I think tensions
have been quite high for a couple of
weeks now these clashes erupted early
around 1 30 a.m local time between these
rival militias and things escalated
quite quickly we saw forces affiliated
with the parallel government led by
Fateh bashara Advanced towards the west
of Tripoli they also advanced in the
south of Tripoli which saw clashes erupt
in and around the capital we saw that
escalate into a serious conflict a heavy
artillery shells Landing in densely
populated areas with no regard to life
just from a few shots being fired to
Heavy Artillery being used it shows you
how quickly things can escalate the UN
the U.S the UK have all called for an
immediate cessation of the hostility and
as a sigh of relief for many people here
in Tripoli we saw forces gathering in
misrata a large Convoy which was headed
towards Tripoli affiliated with bashawa
they decided to go back to misrata now
the forces that entered Western Libya
our military sources are telling us that
they're beginning to return so we are
seeing a sigh of relief but things can
escalate very quickly here in Libya due
to the fragile security situation and
the political differences libyans want a
political Elite to stop fighting on the
streets causing death injury and
destruction among the civilian
population they want to see an end they
want the differences to be settled on
the negotiating table and they want
elections to be held as soon as possible
because they're fed up with political
Elite at the moment